[Music]
i already know nick probably knows all
the information from this article right
here but what
about jake paul and dana white oh yeah
oh yeah do you actually yeah so jake
paul is it juicy jake paul
promises to retire from boxing if dana
white meets his demands what's his
demands
let's cessna
so dana white wants him to retire from
button no dana white doesn't give a [ __ ]
dude he don't give a [ __ ] he probably
just doesn't really care about jake paul
in general but jake paul keeps talking
some smack so he he wants to like fight
one of he generates really good buzz
though he does really good gain up can i
call him is that cool no dude
mr white is a killer promoter yeah he
really is yeah so he'll take advantage
we're not that far from him maybe we
could just go to the ufc office and ask
him what his real thoughts are as a news
channel you know i think dana white
would come on this
i think he would i think he would i
think if you reach out to dana what i
think he would come up i totally think
he's bigger than this i don't know we're
at the trump tower bro like i think he's
banned from the trump that's one of the
few hotels he's not banned yeah him and
trump are actually like good buddies
yeah yeah and like hey you know you know
trump um we're actually we stayed like
they're filming there like he's like 6
202. he's like no way i stay there all
the time that's what dana's going to say
dude you see yeah and we're we bought a
couple of maga hats exactly dude yeah
hey you're media entertainment we're
media entertainment like come on we got
a fifteen you're a white he's a white
guy he's a one actually he's a white and
he's a green yeah
we got a fifteen dollar trump shot glass
you got a 15 trump truck we got it
that's a good price i'm not going to i'm
not going to ditch you i'm not going to
diss you on that one i got a plastic cup
that holds the same alcohol okay so jake
paul has promised to quit boxing of dana
white meets his demands the pair have
been going back and forth in a war of
words for months on twitter see boss
take not taking the youtubers boxing
career seriously
and paul said on numerous occasions that
he wants to get in the ring with another
of white's fighters having just knocked
out ex-ufc welterweight champion
tyron woodley last month specific list
right like nate diaz george mas with all
like he has a specific list aka all the
top people yeah the top guy not
necessarily even like what connor the
top fighters but the ones that bring the
crowd yeah so connor that's pay-per-view
what do you guys think about um the
conspiracy that he's paying people to
take a dive i think it's genius i i
don't think that's i don't think that's
true i think he's actually i think he's
actually knocking out these dudes yeah i
think because you know the other fight
right he kind of like
yeah but that's like that's in boxing
like you could take anything or any
sport like you could watch someone do a
little movement and then if you focus
over analyzing yeah and if it's it's
worse than slow motion right because you
see the movements and they're just way
bigger but it's it's a faint and that
dude tyron woodley got caught slipping
because i'm sure he went in there
thinking like dude i'll beat this fool's
ass he wasn't training it was last
minute and he just got caught
jake did actually execute that like i'm
gonna do a body and you'd like oh and it
opened up and not to speak out of turn
but i do appreciate your commentary on
this because you have gotten knocked out
more than we have more than tyrone
woodley
absolutely coming from a
i did it for free
as a knockout expert with ct
you know what i mean like he's the most
i'm i'm the [ __ ] authority you see
the boxing glove go like this and then
like woke up you know like the next day
one of my first fights where i'm like
like this and this dude
it's one of my favorite photos oh i'll
send it to you what's the count how many
times have you been knocked out i've
never been knocked out oh never been
knocked out only technical knockout
accepted by steve green what about
somebody else out before um not with
like a head shot like not with like
punching in the head and then like
dropping them and knocked him off with
kicking him in the dick what yeah
yeah go to the bottom allowed one dick
kick per match little dick kick dude
dick nick you have to tell the raptor
like i'd like to use my dick
kick is it
right yeah
he checks the
so dana white's been reluctant to allow
any of his stars to cross over to boxing
to fight paul but in his latest offering
jake paul has said that he will retire
from boxing if white allows him to fight
jorge masdal in the ufc val holy [ __ ]
however the 24 year old said he will
only do so if the ufc chief meets a list
of demands including improving pay
for his roster of fighters here's what
you got to give up to the kid about
right yeah
he's rich
he doesn't need to do this [ __ ] no no i
wouldn't [ __ ] do this [ __ ] you think
i want to fight jorge moscow if i'm
[ __ ] if i'm a millionaire no i
actually don't
you know i'll pay a million dollars not
to fight this guy
[Laughter]
that's what i'm saying like this guy he
just sits there he's like he's like a
millionaire all right my life's
beautiful i could go [ __ ] any trick i
want i don't know he's like you know
what i want to do i want to play jorge
basketball
i mean what's crazy is i i believe
he's probably on his way to being a nine
figure dude is paul if he's not there
already so he's really crushing it he
really doesn't have to fight and then uh
when i saw all the conspiracy videos and
stuff i was like oh [ __ ] damn that's
true it does look like it was like he
gave him the signal he's ready to go
down and then i have someone or i know
someone that's really close with tyron
that uh
helped train him for many many many
fights
and i was like hey you know like is it
possible is there even a one percent
chance that he got paid to take a dive
those no there's no way like he
personally knows tyrone and he just has
too much pride as a champion as an
athlete to ever do that because you know
to these guys like
they've these guys that have rose to the
top they've fought for zero dollars
before it's always been about pride and
how good i am and skill and stuff like
that so why would they take the money
now and destroy their legacy no well the
difference is tyrone woodley right in
his in his ufc prime he was making a
quarter million a fight yeah whereas
whether he took a dive or not he made
two million it is life-changing can we
have an actual discussion about this
yeah okay
so if you're
[Music]
tyrone william okay okay
you are it's like hey
you didn't get beat by jake paul you
took a dive isn't that a little more
honorable am i crazy like because
everyone hates jake paul i'm not saying
that i agree with that i'm just saying
like to the outer
world i think it depends on because you
know people value different opinions
differently so it depends if tyron cares
about the opinions of his internal
circle or the public okay right because
if he cares about the opinions of his
internal circle
like i think a lot of us do which is why
uh we can clown on each other but we
know how we really feel in real life so
we don't really give a [ __ ] right like i
don't care if people think i'm [ __ ]
dumb or whatever but if people care
about uh the outside circle
then i think that dictates how he would
move right yeah because to me if i like
it's like hey dude if you have the
excuse it's like dude no i took the l
it's all good dude yeah you know i mean
like
is that a little better than like hey
jake paul knocked me the [ __ ] out he
laid me out dude and after the fight he
was like yeah he caught me with a good
shot and the potential like non-stop
meme forever yeah yeah that's crazy but
here's here's here's the reality of the
situation if jake paul and tyler woodley
were in a dark alley somewhere and they
were to fight
tyra really would murder like a full-on
fight though a full-on fight to the
dublin fight for survival paul would be
murdered by town woodley
uh like eight nine out of ten you're
saying save my box
well it's just because it's a very
specific skill set right and he and jake
paul has more advantage in that skill
set than which is crazy to even think
about well he didn't start there though
choosing his opponents correctly right
yes correct and he's he's uh changing
the terms a little bit here and there
when he decides to fight him on a
two-week notice right but at the end of
the day it's like a guy like tyrone
woodley he just he just got caught and
that's for for guys in mma world their
whole mentality is like they're going to
win some and they're going to lose some
and in boxing it's not really like that
everybody wants to have the o like
you're undefeated but in reality in mma
it's like you can get knocked out but
come back and be world champion which is
more of a testament to like like life
right do you think mma dudes have a
different perspective on winning and
losing for sure and then they're just
like uh took the l come back it is what
it is like there are more dogs than i
think
i might get some slack but they're
probably gonna be a little more mentally
tough than some guys that are
that have a o next to their name that
are undefeated like a pretty boy boxer
yeah because in boxing the culture is
fight the guy you keep fighting bums
keep fighting guys that are two and
seventeen set bums up for you and it'll
keep happening because they want to pad
that record but in mma and the ufc or
most times they're finding the best guys
in the world all the time so you losing
to one of the best guys and it's a
different fight every time you fight a
different guy skill set it's a
completely different fight so just
because i beat up bart doesn't mean i
could beat up anthony or vice versa
right like there's so many more
variables in this sport of mma so for
those guys they're they're used to
taking losses if you could be five you
could be of anthony
i don't think so because that's true i
think there's a freak he beat you up but
he can't beat me up and i'll we should
take that as a heart i think if you beat
bart up you could beat a panther yeah i
don't think it's 100 universal
so back to the story so uh what jake
paul had said on twitter he said happy
new year dana white here's a real
challenge for you i will immediately
retire from boxing and fight jorge
maseratol i'm sorry masquerade mascot
mask masco deal
wow
your pokemon is evolving
i will immediately restart from boxing
and fight jorge mcdonald for mcdonald's
in the ufc if you agree to
one increase minimum fighter pay
per fight to 50 000 it's 12 000 right
now you know what can i say what i love
about that move
jake paul is so good at stirring [ __ ] up
he's challenging the big man right
and then all the entry-level fighters
are already like that's the big guy and
they're probably half [ __ ] him they
don't pay me enough
so he's creating an army by stirring the
bottom of the ocean up and destroying
their own
or loyalty and so now people are like
yeah they know why why don't you pay me
more and don't we all know that all that
matters is the top card so it doesn't
matter that they can fight or whatever
the [ __ ] it's it's the name versus the
name yeah and that's what gets everyone
to pay for the pay-per-view definitely
definitely this instigation tactics are
[ __ ] great very good it's very
amazing
all that matters is your technical
fighting skills no dude marketing is
[ __ ]
the hugest part of it that's where the
money comes in that's why conor would
lost the last three or four fights yeah
if he fights again it will still be the
biggest fight he will love him and he's
probably gonna fight for the title which
is crazy when he comes back that's like
watching chuck liddell the last like 16
years of his [ __ ] career he he lost
every single fight but he's chuckling
down he's chuckling he's the ice man
yeah he's the ice man he's not he's no
steve green he's the other iceman
number two
guarantee ufc fighters 50 of ufc annual
revenues one billion dollars in 2021.
you mean spread it among the fighters
absolutely whoa absolutely dude he's the
people's champion number three provide
long-term health care to all fighters
you previously said brain damage is a
part of the gig imagine the nfl said
that
there are many ufc alums who have
publicly said they are suffering from
brain damage of course
so like barbara said this fool is
stirring a like
realistic as [ __ ] pot definitely the
other part of the other part of it
though
is he's also like um the mis whether
he's misinformed or not he's also like
the misinformed person just just yelling
random stuff like climate change or
whatever because ufc
i believe uh they out of all
professional sports they have spent the
most money on research on brain trauma
and stuff like that so the stuff that
jake paul is yelling at
i think dana white on this honestly
already has it covered and it's part of
the business model of ufc people don't
know so which is why people really
love the usc and it would be so like a
sucking of his own dick if he came out
and said all these things so i don't
know if jake paul knows or he's just
using as a tactic to just stir [ __ ] up
clearly a tactic to drive people because
like social media crews honestly yeah
like someone like me that's like maybe a
casual viewer right or like i'll watch
from time to time and like i don't go
deep like you guys but if i read this
tweet i'm all like man this guy is
really fighting for the [ __ ] little
guy right yeah right yeah they should be
doing this [ __ ] why don't they cover the
health of them like yeah cpi over here
in vegas there's one almost on every
major continent
and it's to help
fighters who can't afford
trainers strength and conditioning
communities or nutrition and all that
stuff i mean uh uh coaches you could
live there you can live there why does
it have to be just fighters
what about the homeless there's so many
homeless in las vegas
it's for there's food there's the like
world-class facilities and the ufc and
has invested and all that stuff honestly
if it wasn't like dana white has really
changed the sport
overall because anyone have that yeah
boxing even have that boxing doesn't
have any of this he's trying to do
something completely new he's trying to
turn into the nfl and dude like [ __ ]
five like six years ago we would be
fighting in an indian reservation yeah
and we'd be warming up in a bathroom
you know it'd be like it's crazy it's
crazy to see how far the sport has a
thousand dollar grand prize not even
dude we fight we we one time i had a
corner a guy the guy he was gonna fight
pulled out 20 minutes before and then
they grabbed some dude from the stands
to fight
my fighter the flight is to go down yeah
yeah and they gave him a 22 revolver
like like the sport came from such a
crazy and it's still there like it's
still there but what dana white's trying
to do is is is make it way bigger than
it already is and it's gonna it sucks
dude you know what's next is [ __ ]
gunfighting dude
context
jake says you have five days to accept
and to implement the above by march 31st
2022 once implemented i will immediately
retire from boxing enter us wait he has
five days to accept by march 31st i
don't know if uh
that's five days his calendar is very
good to accept and to implement the
above by march 34. dana white is like i
don't give a [ __ ] if you retire
and he says to all ufc fighters time to
take a stand and create value for
yourselves and peers you deserve higher
pay you deserve longs from health care
and above all you deserve freedom
support each other i am not your enemy i
am your advocate who selfishly wants to
knock out a few of you to make some big
bang wow
he knows that's pretty crazy yeah yeah
man he's really good at that marketing
boy all right fine fine i'll give you
guys dana white's response before yes
thank you
is he at the wind
he's at caesar's no he's not a seizure
we know he's not
he's bad jake you never responded to the
challenge
you publicly stated that i use cocaine i
do not so i told you you could randomly
cocaine test me for the next 10 years
i believe that you're a cheater and i
believe that you use steroids
so i want to randomly steroid test you
for the next two years
and that thing that you came out with
today
nobody on earth thinks that you really
wrote that you're too stupid
and for those of you that don't know if
you've ever watched one of his fights
and you see when they do the stare down
the guy that's standing in the middle
with the warlock nose and the big
warlock ward on his face
apparently that's his manager and that
guy used to be an accountant for me
and
let's just say this he no longer works
for me and i think he's a scumbag
but
if you two think that you can do it
better than we do uh you know
we're doing this whole thing wrong you
can treat the fighters better than we do
knock yourself out go start your own
business it's easy to do go get the
warlock on it the walmart can get it
started for you
what you and the warlock should be
focused on is your business
you're tanking you can't sell
pay-per-views you know yeah you're
calling out jorge masvidal because he's
a pay-per-view superstar
nate diaz
conor mcgregor mike tyson
these are all superstars you're not
you can't sell pay-per-view so
you do whatever the hell you want to do
i'm ready to roll buddy i don't use
cocaine do you use steroids
let's do this jake
i don't use cocaine while he sounds like
he's just [ __ ] did a lot yeah
yeah i don't do cocaine man
you know you know what he should
actually do jake paul then because they
say he can't get pay-per-views right
okay fine he's like guess what it's me
jake paul i'm gonna fight maggie smith
aka old wendy from hook
all right
that'll be a paper you want a
pay-per-view
hey hey this is dana white's idea you
think i want to [ __ ] punch out maggie
smith
i don't
but i will dana did this
that's how he flips it
genius dude
are you the warlock dude
ah